and he's going to tell us more about
sketching
high dimensional data all right great so
yeah i'll just continue where i left off
on friday
so if you remember friday i talked to
you
um
i talked to you about approximate
counting
and also the distinct elements problem
and here we talked a little bit about
pseudorandomness
and ky's independent hash functions and
then
i gave both an idealized
and a real algorithm
and if you remember the real algorithm
looks something like
we have this data structure that i
called the simple data structure
and we had login instantiations of it
and then we have this hash function
which map the universe into
um into a range of that size or the
probability
that h of i is equal to j was something
like 1 over 2 to the j
right and each one of these data
structures
solved the following problem if the
support size of x
is at most k basically return x
else output you know
x is too dense it has too many non-zero
entries right
so hopefully this sounds familiar um and
you know for our query we basically
started from the bottom we queried
simple log n it probably said that x is
the zero vector or at least
x projected to everything that hashed to
that level was the zero vector and we
worked our way up until we got
something non-zero and once we got that
we got some
kind of rough constant approximation to
the answer to the number of distinct
elements or the support size of x
that let us zoom in on one level that
would provide a good
one plus epsilon approximation and we
got we basically queried that
data structure and then scaled back up
by some two to the j
so that's where we were on friday and
today i want to talk about
a couple things one is i want to talk
about impossibility results proving
lower bounds against uh data structures
or against us you know sketching
algorithms
and i also want to talk about um
something related to a question someone
asked last time
maybe it was daniel actually or i can't
remember who asked the question daniel
de douche maybe someone else
um can you you know how do you handle
deletions as well
and um i want to talk about that because
the way
you know actually this this template of
an algorithm i'm showing
you right here with this login levels
and these simple data structures
it's very easy to turn this template
into something that works for deletions
as well
and one of the tools that will allow us
to generalize to streams with deletions
that tool will also transition well into
the next topic
or another topic which is sketching for
graphs
okay we're going to see we're going to
basically treat graphs
as n choose two dimensional vectors
where n is the number of vertices
n choose 2 is you know the total number
of edges that could exist in the graph
and as you insert and delete edges from
the graph you're basically
updating this underlying vector and
we're going to do some linear algebra
to to get some sketching for graphs okay
so
anyway that's a little foreshadowing but
for now let's continue
along this path and let's start talking
about impossibility results
okay so what did we saw
uh if you want one plus epsilon
approximation
with probability at least one minus
delta for distinct elements
this is possible
in small space
um i told you what the optimal bound is
the optimal bound turns out to be
1 over epsilon squared log 1 over delta
plus log n
i didn't show you the proof of this
bound the balance i showed you know what
follows from what we discussed on friday
is worse than this by logarithmic
factors but you know i i did show you
something that gets you
kind of one or ups on squared log
squared n log one over delta
uh this particular bound as i mentioned
the upper bound is due to
yaroslav washik
in 2018
and the lower bound i gave those
citations on friday
so you know we could the fact that we
can get this
you know spurs on to natural questions
one is
okay did we really need to settle for an
approximation
and did we really need to settle for uh
a monte carlo randomized results like
can we just get something that a
deterministic algorithm that works with
probability one
and what i'll show you is that both of
these forms of slack are necessary if
you want to achieve some linear memory
so we will see
you need both
approximation and randomization
to achieve sublinear memory
specifically if you want to achieve a
little low event memory
so first let me show you why you cannot
hope to solve the problem
deterministically and exactly
you're going to need at least one of
these two so
so claim deterministic
plus exact requires
linear memory
and by the way the fact that you need
both approximation and randomization
this was first shown by
uh a lot of not just insecurity
okay so why do you need linear memory
the proof
is going to be via an encoding argument
and i'll also show a second proof that i
mean
that's very similar but phrase the
language of communication complexity but
first let's just start with this
encoding argument
so the claim is that
if there exists a space s algorithm
that's both deterministic and exact
then there exists an injection
i'll call the injection injection enc
for encoding
that maps n-bit strings
into s-fit strings okay
so of course if this thing is an
injection that already tells you
that ssb at least end right
so what is this encoding
um the encoding
of some string some binary string b
is going to be just the memory footprint
let's call this algorithm a
so if there exists a space s algorithm a
then there's just this injection
this is the memory footprint of a
after being run on the stream
that contains all i
such that bi is one right so
if b is um
your b is you know let's say zero zero
one
one one zero
so these are the indices one two three
four five six
then the stream here is three four five
right
and i'm writing that toward the bottom
but i think you can see that um
right so we have some binary string b
and bits
the n is six here um we just look at
where all the ones are
we put that into a stream we run the
algorithm a
on that stream now it has some s bit
memory footprint
that memory footprint is the encoding
it's
that this is this defines the injection
of the the injection applied to b
okay and how can i prove to you that
it's an injection
i can prove to you that's an injection
by showing you that i can invert it
you know
so uh what's
the encoding inverse of something
um
i'll just call this the decoding
basically
start the algorithm a
with memory footprint d
okay first step
t gets to a dot query
so what is this now this is just this is
just going to be equal to the support
size
of b right and then
for i equals 1 to n
i'm going to say
feed i to a in the stream
and then uh
right let me just write it like this a1
is a.query actually i should have done
it like whoops
and is anyone okay so i don't know what
just happened but
my ipad just got disconnected from the
zoom
what's going on here
okay i'm back in the zoom i think it's
just some internet connectivity issue
unfortunately the whiteboard has uh
completely
died so i need to okay so that's okay i
guess this now i should have learned
from ramon and used uh
ipad used apple notes instead of using
the zoom whiteboard because i guess if
for some reason you get disconnect and
reconnect your whiteboard completely
disappears
so anyway so let's just go back to where
we were
you can see this right very good
so the decoding the decoding applied to
some
memory footprint so what do we do
we say we boot up
a with memory footprint
d and then we say
or should we just do the following so
for i equals 1
to n
uh say t gets a dot query
and then we'll say feed i to
a in the stream so in other words let's
say a dot update i
so we just saw i
and then t prime gets
a dot query
um so what's going on here
basically remember now we booted up a
with the memory footprint from d
right what is d d is the memory
footprint
of a after being run on b on the binary
string b
so right this this here this here is
just the encoding of some b
so the very first time we go through
this loop c is just the support size of
b
then we feed one to the we feed one to
the algorithm
how does that change the number of
distinct elements well
okay i don't know what is happening but
i got booted out of the ipad zoom again
anyone have any idea of why this uh
why this could be happening
i don't know i'm not a zoo i did i did
read an article about
some zoom crashing but this this doesn't
seem to be that right because i do have
i'm still in the zoom it just keeps
kicking me out of my whiteboard and then
flagging on my whiteboard
jalani would you be able to use um the
apple notes
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna use
applebee's because this is
gonna be a problem
so it looks like i have to share my
entire screen
okay so this this is now working
hopefully
with some delay maybe
huh okay good it is it's there it's just
there's some delay so
anyway that's good enough
okay so sorry about that let's keep
going
um so i said
for i equals one to and
t x a dot query
and then i said a dot update i
and then t prime gets a dot query
okay so so what's going on here
um at first
what has a seen in the stream well we
booted up a with the memory footprint d
which is just the encoding of b so
initially what a is seen in the stream
is exactly the support of b
so every time we go through this loop
we're at some
index of i from one to n if i was
already in the support of b
then you know feeding it again to a is
not going to change the number of
distinct elements
right uh but if it's something new that
wasn't already in the support of b
then it will it will change the number
of distinct elements it'll increment the
non-distinct elements by one
right so every time we go through the
loop basically
queer the query will go up by one or it
will stay the same and if it goes up by
one that's something that's not in the
support
if it doesn't go up by one that's
something that wasn't the support
so let's say there's a step of zero here
okay so let's say this is the answer
which initially is the empty
set
and then we say if t is equal to t
prime so the number of distinct elements
did not go up
then we know that this thing was in the
support
right so this this thing here now is
going to be
okay so good so this is this is a valid
uh
this is this inverts the encoding so
i've just shown you that it's an
injection
okay
now another way to just to show the same
lower bound is via
communication complexity
okay and this is a simple case again you
can get more sophisticated but
the idea here is you know you have two
parties
usually they're called alice and bob
alice has some input from some domain
bob has some input from some domain
they both also know some function f
and they would like to compute f after
sending some communication back and
forth
in this case we'll look at we'll look at
the case where um
alice just sends a single message to bob
and then ba so alice based on her input
x sends this message to bob
and then bob based on the message
together with his input
then spits out the answer to the to the
props and
basically outputs the function
evaluation that we want
okay
um so this is one-way communication in
one round basically alice there's one
way because
alice is only talking to bob um in
general in communication complexity you
could have
multiple rounds alice and bob talk
together with each other back and forth
you could have more than two players
we'll talk maybe about that later but
just this is a very simple setting
so specifically for distinct elements
we could say x equals y equals 0 1 to
the n
and f of x y is just the equality
function
we just want to know whether the two
strings are equal so theorem which i'm
it's simple to show but i'm not going to
show it today is that
the communication complexity basically
you need to send at least 10 bits
of communication
to solve equality
okay this is true even if actually they
talk back and forth
okay so now the complaint is
if there exists a space s
algorithm for distinct elements
then there exists a protocol a
communication protocol
for equality where the message length
is equal to s and then by the previous
theorem this implies that
s has to be at least n
okay um and what's the
you know how again it's very similar to
what we just saw
how would you design a communication
protocol for this for this communication
game based on an algorithm for distinct
elements
well alice can just you know
just like as before look at the support
of x
feed all elements in support of x as a
stream to a take the memory contents of
a
and send that as a message to bob so
that's m m is just the memory of a
what's bob going to do now to decide
equality the first thing he's going to
do
is he's going to query a that's going to
tell them the support size of
x okay if the support size of x and the
support size of y
aren't the same then already he knows
that x and y are not the same he can
output node these are not equal strings
on the other hand if x and y do have the
same support size
then what he does next is he just feeds
y into the stream namely the support of
y into the stream
okay and if these two strings are not
equal
there will be something in y support
that's not an x's support
and that will increase the number of
distinct elements so when he when he
queries again for the number of distinct
elements it will have gone up
so if it did go up he can again say no
these are not equal strings and if it
didn't go up
then he knows that yes these are equal
strings and he's decided equality
okay hopefully that makes sense
so again in the language of
communication complexity you can get you
can get the lower bound via
reduction from the equality problem
but this is like this is a common theme
in streaming algorithms if you can prove
that a certain communication problem is
hard
and then show a reduction from that
problem to your streaming problem
that implies that your streaming problem
is hard
okay um so that shows that you can't
have a sublinear algorithm
if it's both exact and deterministic but
what if it's
only deterministic but it's not exact
what if we're willing to have
a one plus epsilon approximation
but deterministic it's always guaranteed
to be a one plus epsilon approximation
you know is that possible
um and we're gonna see no that also
requires linear communication
or linear question yeah
things in your proof i'm not sure i
understand correctly you seem to prove
that you're required to be correct for
all the curious times right
yeah so i'm because you're right that's
right because i was proving that a
deterministic algorithm deterministic
exact algorithm
is impossible in some in your memory but
i can still ask my goal is
to be correct at a specific time does
that change the picture
what do you mean what do you mean by at
a specific time how do you define you
have to stream in data my goal is to try
to
store make make some storage of the data
high c so that
say at a thousand steps i can tell how
many
uh distinct elements there are you mean
you mean
at the end yeah say at the end but i
don't care what in the in between
i'm correct or not right but okay but
the thing is uh like your algorithm
doesn't know when the end is right so
each one of those times that there was a
query
i could have just imagined that that was
the end you said your algorithm had
better be correct there right
i see okay i don't know does that answer
your question
yeah okay
um i mean if you want or if you want me
to say it differently like you know just
imagine that
you know so there were some here in that
for loop there was a some alternating
updates and queries right but i could i
could have imagined
you know every time that i wanted to do
a query just restart the memory at
from scratch at d and then just keep
doing all the updates i did to that
point and then do one query
do that one query and that i mean that's
like the end right
i mean your algorithm doesn't know that
the difference between that and the end
okay but hopefully that made some sense
but
um okay so i want to rule out this too
can i have a deterministic algorithm
that's a one plus absolute approximation
and the answer is
uh i cannot and
the reason is basically um
error correcting code so what i'm going
to do is the
claim is there exists
a subset b of 0 1 to the n
such that first of all
let's say like oops what's going
on hide this um the size of b
is at least you know exponential in n
to
what okay i don't know i'm not saying
anything wrong
yeah okay somehow this thing has a mind
of its own
is it working now no am i even still
your ipad is no longer connected oh it's
not in the zoom at all
so maybe it's actually just an internet
connectivity issue
can you connect your ipad by bluetooth
journey
connect my ipad no i'm it's just
separately on the wi-fi
you don't have a table or something to
connect it to your laptop
um maybe that's possible it's just too
technologically advanced for me
um what kind of laptop do you have
uh i'm just i'm running a bunch of linux
on a thingpad
jelani is there any way to use the
laptop you're currently on
yeah maybe i could try to just use the
laptop itself it does have a touch
screen it's just that it's uh
it's not as good quality
okay so maybe wait just give me one
second
i'm gonna try to rejoin
hmm
yeah it seems like my head got out from
the zoom entirely so
let me i'll try to do this on my laptop
but we'll see how that goes
oh wait okay
well in the meantime there's a question
that's the proof you were going to say
of the work for say approximation so
recently
that does the proof work for c
approximation not just one minus there i
suppose
um the proof i'm going to show you is
specifically for one plus epsilon
approximation
there is another paper by amit
chocobarthy and one other co-author
who's now i'm forgetting right now that
that does that does prove linear lower
bounds even for larger constant
approximations
and by the way my ipad is back in so
i can let's try to do this again
okay so yeah i just wanted to say that
um you know basically there's a code
there's an exponentially large subset of
the
hamming cube such that um all these
things are
far from each other i don't
hear what it is
okay
um professional let me just say that's
another thing so for all b and b
let's say um the size of b
so b is a set or the support size of b i
should say
is equal to say
n over 100 and for all b not equal to b
prime
uh let's say um if we got b
intersect b prime
is at most say n over 100 squared maybe
times some constant times three or
something
so the intersections are quite small
you know how do you prove this you can
prove it by just picking these strings
randomly so
you know if you imagine
each one you know you break up the break
up the bits into
blocks of size 100 so that they're in
over 100 blocks
and then each in each block just pick a
random location and and
make that wide and make the rest of the
string zero
right so that will give you a random
element
and do this now you do this now many
times independently and you get a bunch
of random vectors in 0 1 to the n
and you can prove that as long as you
don't take too many of them you take
exponentially big and n but not too big
but two to a x c n where c is not too
big
then you can prove that with high
probability um all these things satisfy
item two namely that all their pairwise
intersections are small
okay now um
claim you know
one plus epsilon approximation
for apps sufficiently small
implies an encoding
from b into
0 1 to the s
so this implies that s has to be at
least
the logarithm of the size of b right
which is omega does that make sense
and what's the encoding again the
encoding
of uh of a string
b is just the memory contents
i'm sorry memory contents of a
after running on the support of b
okay and what is the decoding
so for the decoder i mean there's
there's an exponential time decoder that
works
so first of all you know the decoder
knows that if it were to query right now
the answer would be you know n over a
hundred right
the number the number of distinct
elements it's seen is that over 100
because it's the support of b
b all the all the b's have support size
the same which is n over 100.
now what it's going to do is it's going
to do an exponential time decoding
it's going to loop it doesn't know what
b is though right it doesn't know what
original string we ran the encoding on
it's going to just guess
b there are only exponentially many
possibilities for b
it's going to just loop over all of them
and try them and for each one
it's going to insert the support of that
into the stream and ask whether or not
the number of distinct elements you know
change significantly
if our guess was correct the number of
distinct elements won't change
so our answer will be within one plus
epsilon of n over a hundred okay
however if our guess sorry if our guess
was correct
then the number of distinct elements
didn't change so our answer will will
approximately not change if our if our
guess was incorrect
then the number of distinct elements
almost doubled
right because if our number if our guess
was incorrect and we're guessing some b
prime then b prime and b have almost
no overlap so almost the entire
support of b prime is disjoint from the
support of b
so we've almost doubled the number of
distinct elements we've seen in the
stream
right and if we have so if we have a one
plus epsilon approximation think of
epsilon as
you know one tenth or something then we
can tell the difference between staying
the same and nearly doubling
okay um so we can we can basically tell
when we've when we've guessed correctly
does that make sense so um
yes all b prime
and b in sequence
and return the first one
where a dot query
basically barely changed you know it
only changed by ten percent or something
so i don't know john you look you look
uh troubled
oh no maybe not maybe i just uh so any
questions
okay okay so um
that's so that shows that you can't you
can't even have a one plus epsilon
approximation that's deterministic
another thing that you could check is
can i have an exact algorithm that's
randomized so i'm willing to succeed
with probably 99
i'm willing to fail one percent of the
time but when i do succeed
i want to have the exact answer an
automation not a not an approximate
answer
and um i think since i lost some time
due to technical issues i'm not going to
spend time on that proof
but you can use error correction codes
again basically the same construction of
codes
to prove again that it implies that you
have an injection from a from a very
large set
to a smaller set therefore x has to be
at least omega n
so you can't have a deterministic
approximate algorithm you can't have a
randomized exact algorithm
so you need to have both randomization
and approximation if you want to get
some linear memory
okay um
so good so you've seen we've seen one
algorithm in out of sync elements both
upper bounds and lower bounds
um i want to move into another topic
um which is graphs for the rest of today
and before i do that i'm going to go
back to distinct elements
and answer a question from friday about
how do you also handle like general turn
style streams where there could be
deletions in the stream
because um the way to the way to solve
that is going to be very related to
the graph thing that i want to show you
so okay so back
back to distinct
elements upper bound
and what if the stream
has deletions
okay so the stream could be like um
one you know one five and then someone
wants to
let's say delete one delete one so red
means delete
and then now we see three so here
the number of distinct elements or the
support size
is two there's the five and there's the
three the ones got deleted
okay so
if you look back at the data structure
we saw before
the one that had all these this login
levels
um
i claim that you can use a similar kind
of setup to solve in the case of
deletions so i called it before the
simple data structure
actually that simple data structure was
solving a problem i'll call
k-sparse recovery
pay recovery 1 k recovery 2
et cetera so what is this k recovery
problem this case verse recovery problem
we want a sketch of a vector x
such that
um we can do updates
so update i comma delta says x i gets
x i plus delta and then we also want
to handle uh queries that work as
follows
if the support size of
x is at most k then return
x else
you know you're allowed to do anything
you're allowed to silently fail i mean
there are versions where you don't
silently fail there are also versions
where you
you just say fail it's not k sparks okay
so in insertion when it's insertion only
handling case for you know solving case
rush recovery was very simple this was
the data structure that i called the
simple data structure
you just remember the first k distinct
you know things you see in the stream
and then if you ever see the cables
first thing
then you just say fail right this is not
a case parts vector anymore and that
uses something like k log
in bits of memory for kilogram memory
um the trouble now is when you have both
insertions and deletions
you know i could i could have a vector
that
starts at zero it gets very dense
because i i see all the coordinates
and then after i see all the coordinates
i start subtracting most of the
coordinates so that only k
are left or at most care left then at
query time
the support size is small even though at
intermediate time steps it was very
dense
at query time support size is small so i
do need to be able to report x
at that query time okay so how do i do
it
um i'll assume
because i wanted to you know i said that
x is a real vector but
we're counting everything in bits here
so we'll assume that
you know uh all
updates are integers
and so we're promised
that you know no entry of x is ever
bigger than say
t some t in magnitude
okay and i can let's round up
so that you know learning are you
writing we only say we're assumed at
least i only say that oh yeah so i am
writing uh
okay so it looks like there's just some
delay here okay okay
yeah uh so round up so that you know t
is a prime power
okay so i just want to say f of ft is a
finite field um
so what are we going to do we're going
to maintain
via we'll maintain what's called a
linear sketch
okay and linear sketching is again one
of these things that's kind of a common
technique in the design of sketching
algorithms and i see that there's still
more lag here
unfortunately so i think
i don't know if it's my wifi or with
zoom because it's weird my laptop and my
ipad are on the same exact
wi-fi network but my my laptop is
working great and my
ipad keeps having these connectivity
issues
hold on
okay so i think i'm back right okay good
the only sketching i should say so the
idea here is we're going to maintain
pi x in memory
where pi is a matrix that's very short
but wide
right remember that x is n dimensional
and pi is going to have only like say m
rows where you know m
is much less than n so the point is
rather than rather than remembering this
huge n-dimensional object in memory
we're only going to remember m things in
memory so it's going to use much less
memory
so the question is how do we then design
this matrix pi
that lets us solve this case parts
recovery problem
and you know not only the matrix but
also the query algorithm that goes
together with the matrix
okay so the matrix pi for us
the case first recovery problem is as
follows
so you know the first column is going to
be 1 x1
x1 squared up to x1 to the m minus one
and then one x two x two squared up to x
two
to the m minus one etcetera one
x n x n to the n minus one
and what's the property we want right
basically we just we want to be able to
do case first recovery which means that
if x and y
let's say x and y are k sparse
and x is not equal to y we want that pi
x
is not equal to pi y because if they're
not equal then at least in principle
you know this this map is an injection
so we can recover
the underlying k-sparse vector and this
is the same thing as saying that
pi times x minus y is not equal to zero
and x minus y here is two k sparse
okay i reached the bottom here so this
is two k sparse
right so what we want is we want the
matrix pi
such that it doesn't have any 2k sparse
vectors in its kernel
right so you know if i pick
a matrix pi like this which is this kind
of van der waal matrix
then what does it mean that to not have
any 2k sparse vectors in its kernel it
means that
if you look at any sub-matrix of pi
formed by taking 2k columns of pi
so take any sub-matrix formatting 2k
columns
that sub-matrix has full column rank
okay which i can achieve by setting m
to be uh basically 2k
right so as long as the x i's are
distinct
and i pick 2k rows then any
sub matrix with 2k columns is a square
vandermond matrix
which i know you know is non-singular
okay
um so good so
so that that basically works okay so uh
um so this is this is the replacement
um for the simple data structure in the
case where i want to also be able to
support deletions
okay so any questions about this i guess
what i didn't talk about is what's the
actual algorithm
you know when i say query how do i get
back the k-sparse vector
so one thing that definitely works is
basically
uh loop over all n choose k
possibilities for where the support
could be and then solve a linear system
and see if what you get back is actually
case bars okay
and the first time you get something
that's actually case force you say here
it is here's the case bars vector
right it might give me something that's
up to two k sparks because i'm solving a
two k minus
two k linear system but if you give me
something with sparsity more than k
then i know that my guess for the
support was wrong
and if it gives me something that is k
sparse then because this thing isn't
is an injection i know that what it
returned to me is the right answer
so that's an exponential time decoding
it turns out that there is a polynomial
time to coding
it takes time roughly k squared maybe
with some log factors
it's basically the same thing as what's
called syndrome decoding
in the correct in the air correcting
codes literature syndrome decoding of
resolving codes it's very similar to
proney's method
if people have heard of that i'm not
going to go over it today
but there is also a time efficient
query algorithm to actually get back the
case bars vector
um okay so
that's basically it if you just replace
the simple data structure with this
then you get something that can also
support deletions so
before i move on now that you've seen
this data structure before i move on
any questions
okay so let's keep going and let's hope
that my ipad stays connected
i'm like i'm holding my ipad at a
certain angle that
i think like maximizes the wi-fi
reception but we'll see whether that
works
okay so
um i want to move into an example of
using this state this
case brush recovery data structure
graph sketch for graph sketching
so there are two models here
um one model is
you have this graph
okay where you can imagine that each
vertex in this graph is some
agent that only knows local information
it only knows its own neighborhood in
the graph so
you know this this um
this person here can only see
basically that you can only see this
edge and this edge
right it only knows stuff that's
connected to it
okay so
in this model of computation um this
look kind of local model
this distributive model here where
everyone has local information you
imagine that there is like some central
server
and then each vertex knowing only the
local information
has to send a message so let's call this
you know this is vertex 1. this is
vertex 2
3 4 5. vertex 1 will send a message
based on instant information m1
to the central server this will also
send a message
m3 this will send a message m2 etc
and then the central server then has to
compute the answer
for example give me a spanning tree of
the graph
or is you know is the graph connected or
find me the minimum spanning tree or
find me you know matching
of minimum cost you know min cost max
matching or something right whatever
graph problem i want to solve you can
imagine this distributed model
and then the other one is streaming
and here we're going to look at you know
edges
are inserted
and deleted
from an n vertex graph
in a streaming fashion
so there's some log file at facebook
where every time some user becomes
friends with another user or
removes a friend because they know they
had an argument i can see in my log that
so and so are now friends so and so have
ended their facebook friendship
okay so i see this in a streaming
fashion and then at query time
i want to compute something about the
graph again i want to find a spanning
forest or whatever
okay now
you know in principle a graph on n
vertices could have up to n squared
edges
so you know in the streaming model you
could imagine needing n squared memory
to remember what you need to remember
about the graph to be able to answer
later queries
turning in a lot of graphs a lot of huge
graphs like the
internet graph facebook graph etc there
is kind of bounded average degree
usually you don't have n squared edges
okay
but in principle you could have up to n
squared edges so a trivial algorithm
would use
n squared memory and again
you know in the other model model number
one
kind of a trivial thing that you could
do is
each vertex sends its entire
neighborhood to the central
server but its neighborhood could have
size
you know up to n minus one right so you
would be sending the central server
a message of length linear in the in the
graph size
okay so the question is can we you know
these models you know for various graph
problems can we do better
and kind of a theorem
this is due to on guha
and mcgregor in 2012
is that for model like for for let's say
spanning forest
in model one you can get all the
messages
to have length at most log cube done
and then for model two
you can get space at most
o of n log cubed in
and by the way these are both watching
you and myself showed
that these are actually both optimal we
showed this
here okay
so i want to show you um how ongoing
mcgregor's thing works in the last
five minutes i'm not going to show you
all the analysis but you'll get the bait
you'll get
most of the iud
okay so first remember now you've seen
this case sparse recovery data structure
um so we'll use something called we'll
call the support find
data structure
from uh johari
sagalam and tardish
okay what does this do
this is um query so
this is basically when someone says
query
you return any i
in the support of x okay x might not be
k sparse x is allowed to be dense
okay but you know if if x is the
non-zero
if x is not the zero vector just give me
any index in the support of x
okay um how do you harry sanchez and
tardis solve this
the basic idea is looks you know it's a
similar picture to what you've seen a
couple times already
you basically have log n levels
you have a hash function
the probability that h of i is j is
roughly one over two to the j
now what are each of these boxes each of
these boxes are k recovery data
structures
so it looks it looks a whole lot like
the distinct element sketch
right um
and now the point is you know you just
uh oh my running out of it
that i lose connection again because i
can see that the bottom box is not
filling in
okay well anyway i can just talk as it's
loading now there it is okay good
so so what's the idea here like the idea
is
look so x has some support size right it
might be huge might not
think of k here as a okay great
uh am i getting disconnected think of k
here is like a constant
okay so x has some support size it's
probably not you know it might not be
constant
it could be as big as n but you know
roughly half the support gets hashed to
the top box
a quarter of the support gets hashed to
the second box
one end of the support gets hashed to
the bottom most box
right so um
sorry jelani it's uh let's see i think
i'm
uh okay so i'll just talk even though
you can't see the image and i'll try to
reconnect as i'm talking
so if you look at that picture right so
the point is probably none of the
support
hashed to the bottom most level right so
if you query that it's going to tell you
oh x is the zero vector and then you
know
probably also nothing has to level right
above that etc until
until you get to a level where level j
where
you know the support size over to the j
is a constant
when the support size over two to the j
is a constant then
you know you're going to get you're
going to get a non-z with a good
probability you're going to get a
non-zero vector at that level so when
you query it
you'll get it back and then now you can
just return any entry in that vector as
being the support of the original vector
okay so that's how they solve that
now how do you use that data structure
to solve say spanning forest
and that's the thing that i need my
board back for unfortunately this is
yeah i'm very sorry i think maybe when i
you know tomorrow maybe i'll have to go
into
a different room i i have great wi-fi
connection on my ipad it's just
zoom keeps kicking me out i did see an
article
about zoom dying on everybody in the
country today
uh i don't know if this is part of that
but you all are connected just fine so
maybe not
i saw samson had a question here the
distribution of i
is roughly uniform for the support um
i think you're asking that question for
the support find data structure
uh if so there is a way to get that
that property but for me it doesn't
matter as long as i get anything from
the support i don't care whether it's
uniform or not
okay so
let's just try this last part i will
write on my actual laptop
okay so are you seeing this
yeah okay good um
okay so now the idea is like
x is going to be in r
and choose two right where
um x e corresponds
to like the to a possible edge e
that could be in the graph
and let's pretend that like you u is
less than v
okay so there are all these vertices in
the graph
and vertices um
let's say that this is vertex 1 vertex 2
vertex 3 etc
i'm actually going to have n different
vectors not just one
where this is vector you know x1
this is vector x2 etc this vector x3
and each one of these vectors is going
to store the edges that are incidents
upon that vertex
so x1 is only going to store edges
that touch vertex 1. so for example
if vertex 1 has edges to
4 7 and 9 then x1
is going to look at like this so 1
2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9.
does that make sense okay
and let's say that vertex 9 only has an
edge to 1
then x9 is going to look like
minus one zero zero zero zero
zero zero where i put a minus one
because nine is bigger than one
so you know that that edge appears in
two vectors the edge of 1 9 appears in
the x1 vector and it appears in the x9
vector
but in the x1 vector oh sorry sorry i
just realized
this is not how i wanted to draw it so
um this is not what i wanted to do
give me a second
these are not n-dimensional vectors
these are n-choose two-dimensional
vectors
right so there's basically an entry
corresponding to the potential edge one
two
to the potential edge one three to the
potential edge one four
to potential edge one five as well as
the potential edge um 2 3 to the
potential edge
2 4 to the potential edge 2 5 etcetera
there are n choose 2 entries
now in the one not in the 1 4 entry
there's going to be a 1
in the 1 7 entry there's going to be a 1
and the 1 9 entry there's going to be a
1 this is the 1 7 entry
this is the 1 9 entry whereas x 9
in the 1 9 entry there's going to be a
minus 1
and there's going to be zeros everywhere
else
does that make sense so these are all
entries two dimensional vectors and
you know that edge 1 9 appears in two
vectors the one vector and the nine
vector
and by convention in the one vector
it'll be positive
and the nine vectors will be negative
okay so in the in the larger of the two
indices it'll be negative okay so
if every if every vertex stored its
corresponding vector
exactly we we you know this is a
lossless uh
track of information about the graph but
you know now i've
i'm storing n cubed uh dimensions
basically
right and they're basically n squared
entries here and they're n vectors so n
cubed
so it's pretty bad however what i'm
going to store
is not the vector but i'm going to store
the sketch of the vector
i'm going to store pi x 1 pi
x 2 up to pi x n
where here this pi
is the j s t data structure the jahari
saglam tardis data structure
that solves support find
if you remember it was login levels of
linear sketches
but login levels of linear sketches is
itself just one big linear sketch just
stack the matrices on top of each other
okay so now
what's the what's the actual um
how do i do i think this new white word
i know i'm running low
so let me let me try to wrap this up so
let's pretend let's fake run this on a
graph so here we have one
i said there's four seven i don't know
so we just do it
so two five three
seven four six
eight nine take this graph
okay so initially we don't know anything
we don't know any edges in this spanning
forest
so initially one two
three four five six seven eight
nine all these vertices are singletons
each storing pi times their respective
vectors
now we can ask we can ask pi x1 we can
ask that data structure support find
give me anything in your support what
does that actually mean
it means give me an edge that's incident
upon vertex 1.
that's what it means right
so you know it's gonna give me something
in the support so maybe it's gonna give
me five
it's gonna give me one five one five is
in the support which means there's an
edge from one to five
okay and then we're gonna ask two give
me something in your support
and then maybe two will also tell me
five
two five isn't the support
and then we're gonna ask three well
there's only one option here three's
gonna give me seven
we're gonna ask four et cetera et cetera
okay so let's say four gives me six
six also gives me four and then eight
gives me nine and nine gives me eight
so this is what i got from my support
fines so now what do i know i know that
all these blue edges are edges in the
graph
so i can contract them and i'm learning
about my connected components i'm
learning that one and five
and two are in the same connected
component i know that three and seven
are in the same connected
component etc so now i know that
basically i have this one connected
component which is like one two and five
are all together
and i know that three and seven are
together and i know that
four and six are together
and i know that 8 and 9 are together
now i would like to have that data
structure
that support find data structure that
tells me edges that leave these
tell me an edge that leaves the
component one two five tell me an
edge that leaves the set of vertices
three seven
that crosses that cut that goes outside
this set
how can i get a data structure for these
components though
and the beauty is the beauty of the agm
sketch
is that i can get that just by adding
the data structures
right if i look at pi
x1 plus pi x2
plus pi x5 this is just
pi times x1 plus
x2 plus x5
okay i can get this just by adding
and now what does this do remember now
any edge that is inside of this set that
doesn't cross the cut
it appears twice in these vectors once
positively and once negatively right
like for example the edge one
five it appears positively in x1 and
appears negatively in x5
so when i add them together it gets
zeroed out
so when i look at the vector x1 plus x2
plus x5
the support of that vector is the set of
edges
which cross the cut one two five versus
the rest of the graph
so later in the next round when i query
one two five
i'm gonna get an edge that leaves one
two five in this case there aren't any
but for example for four six there are
edges that leave four
six they go to eight toward eight nine
right so in the next level
i can hope to get some edge that crosses
this cut
right and what you can prove is
basically after you know o of log n
levels of this
um i will have found the final list of
connected components in the graph
okay there are some there's some small
technicalities here like
in each of the rounds of these of this
you know edge discovery i can't use the
same pie
i have to actually use a different fresh
pie in each round because there's
correlation and randomness you know that
that's something that you can deal with
uh but at the end of the day if you do
this right you'll get a you'll get a
space bound of n
log q dead
okay um okay so
i think i'm over time i'm sorry again
about the connectivity issues i'll try
i'll try to present from a different
room of my house tomorrow where the
wi-fi is stronger
um any any questions
any additional questions
okay seems good so let's say thank you
and thank the audience also for the
patients
with the human difficulty uh we're all
done
today is there still a tea time nike
i'm not sure actually i think it might
be announced over the email
so okay yeah so check check get the time
for
social activities
thanks joanna all right